All eyes are on Scarlett Johansson now that
Black Widow has finally hit theaters and Disney+.
With Black Widow, Natasha Romanoff has
finally got the solo film she always deserved,
which takes place between the events of 2016's
Captain America: Civil War and 2018's Avengers:
Infinity War. And while everyone knows that
Natasha doesn't make it out of Avengers:
Endgame alive, Black Widow is still
a fun ride with a compelling story;
one that also introduces a host of
brand new characters to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe. The film's post-credits
scene returns the story to the present day,
where the audience is painfully reminded
yet again that Natasha is no longer with us.
As difficult as it is for Marvel
fans to relive Natasha's death,
it wasn't as hard of a pill for
Johansson to swallow.
The actresshas been busy promoting her new film,
and in an interview with BBC Radio 1,
she revealed what it was like to find out that
Natasha was going to meet her demise in Endgame.
Of course, when the time came to tell Scarlett
Johansson that Black Widow was going to meet
her ultimate fate, there was only one person
who could make the call. Johansson told Radio
1 that Marvel Studios president Kevin Feige
was the one who let her know about Natasha's
fate - and she admitted he seemed kind of sad
about being the one to tell her. She said:
"I think he was nervous to tell me and sad
about it, saying something along the lines of,
'We all expected that there would
have to be some big sacrifices.'"
As far as handling the news, Johansson
apparently took it rather well. She recalled:
"It didn't surprise me that that was
a choice that Nat would have made.
I knew that she had to feel at peace with that
decision and that she was doing it out of love."
As gutting as it was to lose Natasha in Endgame,
fans will have to prepare themselves for
a future without Johansson's character,
as the actress has revealed she has absolutely
no plans to return to the role in future. In an
interview with Fatherly shortly after the release
of Black Widow, Johansson delivered unsurprising
yet predictable news - that this standalone film
is the last we'll see of this beloved character.
She did, however, hint that her relationship
with Marvel is far from over. Johansson said:
"It feels like a great way to go out
for this chapter of my Marvel identity.
I would love to be able to continue
to collaborate with Marvel in other
ways because I think there's just an
incredible wealth of stories there."
Though this may be the end of Johansson's tenure
as Natasha, however, that doesn't mean the moniker
of Black Widow will necessarily be retired
going forward. As fans learned in the film's
post-credits scene, Yelena Belova, mourning
the loss of her late adopted sister, has been
driven into action by the mysterious Contessa
Valentina Allegra de Fontaine. It's entirely
likely that Yelena will step into Natasha's shoes
and take over the mantle in future MCU projects.
Natasha herself, though, leaves behind an
impressive legacy in the MCU - especially
considering her origins. Johansson herself has
even recently criticized how the character was
first treated when she arrived in the
MCU. Back in 2010, Johansson joined the
superhero franchise in Iron Man 2, but after
fully realizing the character for years,
Johansson admitted that she's fairly
unhappy with her character's roots.
Describing the character's evolution during a
roundtable discussion with
the press, Johansson said:
"I mean, you look back at Iron Man
2 and while it was really fun and
had a lot of great moments in it, the
character is so sexualized, you know?"
"That will be all, Miss Rushman, thank
you very much." "I want one." "No."
She went on to say:
"Now people, young girls, are
getting a much more positive message,
but it's been incredible to be a part of that
shift and be able to come out the other side
and be a part of that old story, but also
progress. Evolve. I think it's pretty cool."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.